HISTORY HERE AS A FRANCHISE.
PREDS GOT TO PLAY THEIR GAME.
IT'S A HAD A VERY ACTIVE
PRESEASON.
TRENIN HAD A BUNCH OF GOALS.
WE'LL SEE SHOT FROM THE POINT
HANDLED BY SAROS, OF A FULL TRAG
CAMP.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR IDENTITY IS
AND WHAT THE
>> THIS IS WITH ALEXANDRE CARRI.
IT WILL BE CARRIER TO
SMASHVILLE AND ALL OFF THE FACE.
SEATTLE WILL COME OUT WITH IT
EBERLE UP T T DONATO
AND SAROS MAKES THE NICE MOVE BY
WENNBERG.
>> WELL IF YOU WATCH THE
MOVETH BOX
AFTER SEVEN PENALTY MINUTES,
REALLY TURNING THE GAME BECAUSE
THEY GOTTER THAT FIRST POWER
PLAY AFTER ON
BALLY SPORTS SOUTH.
ACC FOOTBALL ON BALLY SPORTS
SOUTH IS OFF
THEA BIG POW IT FINDING HIS
HE GOT CAUGHT OUT THERE WITH THE
LONG SHIFT.
HE ENDS UP KRAKEN BACK O O S PAO
EKHOLM, MAKING MOST OF THE
CHANCES FOR FIVEL.
JOSI COMES OVER.
BLOCKED MAINLY BY SCHWARTZ AND
DID A NICE JOBD GRANLUND DRIVIN.
HITS FABBRO WHO HAVE THEM HERE N
THE ROPES, JUST PRESSURED WITH
THATE QUICK ANGLEACHES OUT AND .
AROUND 2:30.
THERE BY PHILIP TOMASINO.
IT UP.
BUSTS BACK INITIAL SHOT, BUT THE
KRAKND
GRANLUND SAYS HOLD ON.
THIS THING DOWN THE PUCK.
22 SECONDS TO